非常的快对吧
那接下来我就要做个事情
就是我要把这些光子注入到这个世界
对不对
然后呢
我把这个世界先获得直接的第一次光照的结果
然后我基于它我就可以算我的第二次光照结果
但实际上没有那么简单了
但是呢一般讲lumen的时候呢
很多人一上来就讲什么screen space的一个pro对吧
讲了这个怎么采样啊
怎么点
反正我看到那一趴我就晕掉了
我说我大概知道你在讲什么
但是我的第一反应就是老哥
你不是应该先把光打进去嘛
对不对
你会发现他讲到最后的时候会给你讲一讲
光是怎么打进去的
但是呢我们这节课反过来讲说哎
那实际上就是在这个lumen里面
他搞了一套非常特殊的东西
叫做mesh car
我先不讲mash car的这个细节
我先讲这个我们到底要解决什么问题
就是当我们算全局光照的时候
其实从光的视角我们去照亮整个世界的时候
其实整个世界里面
无论你看得见的还是看不见的pixel
它实际上都会被这个光给照亮对吧
那么这些每一个被照亮的照亮的这个物体表面
我们叫做比如说叫facet小表面吗
它实际上呢都是为我的这个GI的一个贡献者
就是我的光源之一
但是呢我们有个困难
就是说这么复杂的场景对吧
很可能是一个我现在看不见的一个石头的表面
被光打到了
它会照到我了
那你用rs版的话
那你实际上就是用光的方向投了一个投影
但是呢rs m的话呢
你只能作为一个is bing对吧
它很多地方它是有这个比较大的局限性
而且呢就是说这个表面上的话
很多复杂的几何的细节我们都不知道
那么在lumen里面
他提了一个什么方法呢
哎他想了一个办法
就是怕场景
你所有的物体啊
我给他拍了个快照
但这个快照拍的方法呢其实是以相机精度
相机的位置为这个RAVVLOD的
就是说我靠近我
相机占领
我离我的这个相机的位置比较近的这个物体
我会给你的分辨率会高一点
然后呢相机远离的物体
我面前低一点
但是呢我从六个角度拍你的快照
就是拍什么拍照就是你被光照亮的样子
因为我并不知道这些光经过一次帮两次帮形
到底是你天顶上的东西照亮的东西呢
还是你这边侧面的东西
还是这边
也许我看
比如说我举个例子啊
比如说我以我这个笔为例
你真正我眼睛看到的就这一个面
对不对
但是呢有可能是你这个面上一个面照亮了
这边一个面反射给我了
对不对
那么有可能是上面这个面对吧
被光照了诶
这样过来一个东西
那我怎么办
我就对这个物体啊
六个面给他拍这个六四快照
这个就比较麻烦
就大家知道GI就很麻烦
因为GI它是个全光路的
就direct lighting
很多时候你只要在乎我眼睛看过去的东西
但是呢我做JI的时候
我需要知道它的全光路到底发生了什么
那么对于每一个物体
我对对它六个面进行采样
我想知道它被光直接照亮
被光照亮的是个什么样子
而这样的话呢我六个面拍下来
你觉得这里面举个例子
就是说比如说这是这是我们在应用里面
我们自己截的
我们自己搭了一个场景
然后呢你可以看到就是这是它的生成的一个car
这个car的话呢
每个car的它有六个面对吧
你们看到这个细节没有
它其实呢他是用a b b box
就是用那个轴对称的
沿着那个XYZ轴做的这样的一个面
这样也尽量简单一点吧
好我生成了他的car的之后呢
诶我就会首先把cut
把这个物体从这个角度我拍下去
我拿到什么呢
拿到他的ABELE
拿到他的normal
拿到的它的一个depth
depth是从绑定开始算的
所以精度不用很高
如果你带反射的
带发射的自自发光源的话
我把你miss也发出来
所以大家看到真正的GI确实是很丰富
很复杂
就在于就是我场景里每个物体都要排好
那场景物体是很多
对不对
有些物体其实离我很远
有些物体很小
那怎么办
哎我其实是有一套这个啊
应该在这一趴
就是说它实际上是有一套的方法
就是说当你我的相机近的时候呢
我给的分辨率高一点对吧
我拍的更细一点
比如说我侧面有一个石头
这个石头可能只有2米高
但是呢它可能占据了我平面1/3的地方
那我平面近处的东西
很可能会受这个石头的影响
远处呢可能有个雕像
它有5米高
但它距离我100米远
那其实呢我这个car的不用给它太高
它的精度可以低一点诶
大家这个思想就是这样的话
我可以怎么样呢
我可以充分的利用我这个我能存储它的空间
那我存储这些CR的就是那个mesh card
地方在哪里呢
这个东西我们叫做surface cash
哎
这个surface cash就非常有意思了
它总共分配了一个4096×4096的
这个空间
把每一个这个instance就是每一个mesh的
就其实这边准确的讲应该是每一个instance
注意啊
就是说你两个mesh可能是从几何上一模一样
但是你放了两遍
那就是instance
注意这里面是讲的是instance
每一个instance它的car在里面packing好
它总共只有4096×4096这么空间
所以呢它这里面就会有些
随着你的相机的移动啊
随着你的这个就是说主要是相机的移动对吧
那我有些物体就可能会被swap out
有些物体就会被放进来
没关系
因为这个CD你的东西呢主要是用来做GI的
所以呢你多放几个物体
少放几个物体死不了人对吧
因为dear collection不需要用这个东西好
那么这个surface这个cash呢
这里面特别容易混淆的一个东西是什么呢
就是它不是一个单张的texture
它是一系列的texture
这个cash形成的集合
它这里面会包括什么呢
会包括他刚才讲到的
比如说他的ABE对吧
包括什么呢
它的normal对吧
还包括他的depth
对不对
那这样形成了一处东西好
那这里面的话你capture的这些东西的话呢
每一层的这个AIDO啊
or pity啊
这个它的depth啊
他的normal都会用一些硬件支持的
这个compression method去压缩一下
很简单吧
我们做所有的rendering都知道
我要让内存尽可能的小对吧
4096×4096已经很大了
大家想想看这个什么都不干
4096×4096
他就是16个兆了对吧
你还有这么多层对吧
轻轻松松给你上百兆的空间就给你用掉了对吧
那这个就是我们的surface cash
这样的话我有了这样surface cash之后呢
接下来我干什么事情呢
就是说我们如何这个我用这
这这个标题是我自己写的
就是说其实他前面有很大一部分工作
就是当一个光照进来之后
这些光啊
其实在我的这个场景里面直接照亮了一些东西
对不对
照亮这个东西可能是它的正面
可能是它背面
可能是在反面
I don't really care
哎
这些光还可能在里面
BS对吧
BS的一大堆我也不care
但是呢最后我希望这些radiance
最后能存储到我的surface cash上去
为什么呢
因为想象一下我的这个世界啊
本来是很多很复杂的几何
当我去做真的各种各样的全局光照的时候
实际上我的一个问题就是如果我看到了一个点
我去做一个采样诶
我想知道他的那个地方
它到底radiance有多少
那我如果直接在那个就是这个几何事件里面
去问那个面片
你的光热是多少
实际上的过程是非常非常复杂的
而且每一点的材质都是不一样的对吧
但是呢如果我把整个这个世界
它的最粗的这个光照信息
用这么一种uniform的方法表达出来之后
我在这个世界
你无论做什么样的一种retracing的话
就是那个蒙特卡罗retracing的时候
我去都能够采样到那个点的表达
所以你可以理解成
就是说surface cash是对这个世界的一个
就是光照信息
其实就是为我们india lighting
光照信息提过一次表达
我们希望把这个那个这个radiance arradius
固化在上面
这个这个地方又又又去那个怎么说呢
又去祭出了我们的风头
map这个想法就是说其实呢他用这个就是surface card
这么多的那个mesh card
把它packing成一个surface cash的话
实际上是把所有的风头光子全部固化在上面了
哎这个我这个土法炼钢
我是这么理解这个事情的
那么在这里面的话呢
我们就产生了一个问题了
两个问题
第一个就是说这个pixel就是那个service开始那个点
它在这个光的照耀下
它到底有多亮对吧
它有可能会被shadow挡住的
对不对
那我怎么去知道这件事情
第二件事情是什么呢
哎这里面我只有一次的
第一次我竟然知道你的AIO
知道你的normal对吧
那我可以跟主光源算出来
说到你这儿的第一次的这个光照的强度都大
但如果你是mt bs
我怎么办对吧
我因为我到处收集光的时候
这个光照上我我也不知道你是1month n次month
但是最后我要把这个视频方的光源全部收起来
所以呢这其实就是我怎么去在surface cat里面做lighting
哎这里面这个就比较复杂了
这也是其实我觉得lumen比较难懂的部分
这张图呢是我们土法炼钢自己画的
其实包括一些名词
我自己都优化掉了
比如说啊
其实他这个时候最核心的呢
要生成一张什么图呢
就是下面那张图叫surface catch final lighting
不好意思
那张图我觉得我应该标个不同的颜色
就是说service cash
我们刚才讲了不是有四张图吗
有abele normal对吧
OPPITY还有什么呢
还有他的这个呃depth对吧
但是其实啊你这么多都有了之后
我给你一个光在场景里面
其实他最终是要选出他一张lighting图的
这因为这张lighting图上面就储存了
乘上百万的小灯泡
它是我lumen工作的整个基础
好
那我怎么样的算他的lighting呢
我的这里面我自己肉身标记了三步
第一步呢
实际上呃你用一个最简单的方法做它的direct light
很简单
就是说对于surface concash上的每个像素
它的空间就有个位置对吧
那我跟黑跟光源对吧
算一个它的设定值
但这里面的话呢
其实刚到五炮的第一个问题就是
如果你的沙雕力怎么办
那很简单
我做过shine map对吧
我用光年做SHTP
我其实知道visibility
至少我不会错的太离谱对吧
那么第二步呢其实是比较复杂的
就是他为了做这件事情的话呢
他在word space里面其实建了一批这个对光的这个
WORKALIZED的表达
诶
他很多计算机是基于这个WORKLIFE的表达
那这个表达为什么这么这么重要呢
因为你有了这个表达之后呢
你上一帧的这个WORKALIZED的这个光的表达
可以被这一帧就是它的第三步可以采集回来
然后呢采集回来
这个采集回来不是只是采集一根光线
它实际上是回很多根光线
这样我就能够猜出surface上的delighting长什么样子好
我猜出了你的INDIRELIGHTING长什么样子
我把这两个合到一起
就变成了我的这一帧的这个final lighting
诶
我从我的这一帧的final lighting呢
我又把它采样成这个workspace workalized的表达
这个这个放在哪呢
给他下一针用
你现在这个时候很绕
就是这个替云纵左脚踩右脚
左脚踩右脚
但是呢这个东西他这个方法其实是非常的巧妙
但这个方法其实呢也不是他首创的
其实在以前老的一些ROG上也抢到这个id
就是说我们的光啊
在每一次render的时候
我只算他的一次bouncing对吧
但是呢我去再采样一个上一帧里面的那个一次
BING的数据
我用那个一次SPONSE数据
对我这个你的每一个空间点进行lighting的时候
我把这两个lighting效果叠加在一起
实际上是什么呢
它就已经是二次BING了
诶这个在数学上大家可以自己去推一下
那我随着时间的积累
你比如说第一针的时候只有一次BING对吧
当T加F0
我们一般叫F0到F1的时候
其实我就有这个两次BC的值了
我F2的时候
其实我就有三次BBC的值了
它实际上这个猫体方形的数值
就可以一次的积累
其实在那个呃如果我没记错的话
应该在那个SSGI里面
其实他可以用这个思路也做这个MULTIPING的结果
对吧
你就要从previous frame取出去
你其实一样可以做这样的一个事情
所以这个呢是他的LILIACTION
一个很关键的一个思想
那这个东西的话其实讲起来比较复杂
我不不是特别有信心啊
完全给同学们讲清楚
但是呢我尝试把它梳理一下
所以呢大家看到我这边人人肉
打了一个很大的标记叫123
那我接下来就从一步
两步三步给大家去讲一下哇
已经两个小时了
好刺激
那吉尔和拉丁刚才也讲到了非常简单
第一步对吧
那我很简单
就是说我对这个这个配置的话呢
我就是每一个配置我去找这个lighting对吧
那我呢就是sampling一个shadow map
我就知道这个shine map
我就知道我这个点实际上对这个东西有没有
那shine map怎么怎么去sample里呢对吧
那很简单
我也不用真的渲染沙滩map
实际上大家想到了我RETRING是不是很方便啊
对不对
我就在我的SDF里面去走啊对吧
我就是我眼睛看到那个mesh cash
那个那个那个点
那个点的话
它空间上有个位置
然后呢
我就去问他和光的那个那个点和光的连线
我做一个
我再发一条光线
那我用SDF1查
我就知道了
这光线到底是可见不可见
所以刚才你看我画了那么多屏幕
讲retracing
这个时候就已经用上了
对不对
哎那这时候我就可以把这个direct lighting就算出来
因为我知道你的AIDO
我知道你的法向
我又知道你的光长多大
那我自然就知道你的那个direct lighting是怎么回事
对吧
当然这里面假设就是点光源那个方向光源
或者是那个那个那个spotlight对吧
好那么如果你有多光源怎么办
哎它其实很简单对吧
它它就是说那那很简单
那就是我对于每一个
就是这个这个这个那个那个那个surface cash
里面的一个text的话
我一个往下算一遍
把你们累加在一起就可以了
因为我这个是当个小电小电灯泡用的是吧
我也不care我
我我假设我是一个defuse面的一个反射对吧
所以我就可以把这些光累加在一起
这个东西其实非常的重要
为什么呢
就是大家想想看
我今天做所有的GI的算法
如果我假设场景里只有一个光源
有积压效果的话
很可能是不可能
因为当时当artist真的去构建这个环境的时候啊
它的光啊是可以随便打的
他会给你一个主光
然后呢做个场景场景里面再放个光
我这个地方是不能限制那个designer的
所以的话呢这个时候其实任何一种for real time
那个for gaming的就是for游戏实战用的解压算法的话
他一定要支持多光源
你看这样的话它就会非常简单的支持了多光源
而且效率还非常的高
好诶
这个时候啊
这个时候呢我们要做第二件事情
就是说这个如果我们去去采样这些
这些光的时候啊
实际上我们实际上呢就是在在这一趴
跟大家讲一下
就是诶稍等
Promission information
就是说我们对进行光源形采样
其实这个它只能对于很近的物体有用
为什么呢
因为如果我们去踩得非常远
它就会出现一个什么问题啊
出现就是说我们那个要hit掉很多的物体
对不对
所以我们真真正能精确的知道你hit到哪个物体
hit到他哪个表面的这种recasting啊
他其实做不远
那我这个时候我要去求一个点对吧
他的那个那个cashing
他的cash lighting
如果跑的特别远程嘛
我就必然要用那个前面讲的那个global的SDF
但是GLOBTF他有个大问题是什么呢
他只能找到采样点对吧
他只能找到他的normal
但你并不知道你hit到了哪个instance
哪个物体
所以那时候怎么办呢
他就想到了一个办法
他说啊对于近处的物体
我可以精准的把一个物体表面的这个采样的
这个radiance给你达到
但是对于远处的物体又怎么办呢
我把整个场景以相机为中心
做了一个MOLISE的表达
这样的话你的瑞只要你用global sdf hit到了
那我就给你提供一个那个点上的亮度
因为那个点上亮度我就能做我的灯泡了
对吧好
那传统艺能就来了
很简单
我做一个clip map对吧
这个clip map里面的话呢就是我四层
然后呢每一层64×64个
这个WAKO它这里面的数据非常有意思
就是说他每个WORKO我们查了一下是0.78米
哎我们的同学还是很强的
我们真的是看原代码就能看出来的
0.78米
然后我们反算了一下
为什么是0.78呢
应该是0.78×64
好像正好是50×50米
哎我觉得这个这个这个就是哦
这个原作者应该是一个公制单位的热爱者
因为你知道很多美国人是用什么英尺啊
这种东西我就用的特别头疼吗
但是用米的话
一个是欧洲人
欧洲人喜欢用米对吧
那就是说啊他就是50米乘50×50米
那这样把它缩到一个3D的texture里面
那这样的话对于每个OXO呢
我在六个面存储它这个亮度
这样的话其实我再去做这个就是image cashing
我做那个intro lighting的时候
其实我就可以去永远hit他一个东西了
这个东西其实在后面非常的有用好
OK那怎么去对空间进行采样呢
刚才讲的就是
比如说在那个比如说SBUGI里面
比如像那个VXGI里面呢
它一般都是用保守观察号的方法去做对吧
但是呢在这个lumen里面
他的方法呢就比较巧妙
因为他觉得我既然整个场景我都是有这个mesh
SDF表达了
对不对
那我就用SDF啊
它很简单
他就说他先呢就是说找了一个
他把这个这个WALKMAN呢分成大概是我如没记错
是44的这个tile还是更小一点
或者每个WORKO
他其实就知道这里面有多少个incident
大家想象一下
如果在12米的范围里面
你不可能框太多的mesh对吧
然后呢我从它的这个边上
比如说这条边我可以随机的设一根锐进去
如果我能打中任何一个mesh的话
实际上表示什么呢
我这works里面是不会空的对吧
而且我能采样出来你的这个法向啊
你的颜色啊
这些东西其实他就是没有用到硬件的
Rust riser
直接用他的mesh sdf
他就可以获得自己的这个vocalize
的这个世界的表达
所以你可以看到就是整个lumen
他的很多计算机基础啊
用的全是F
但这里面还有很多的细节
比如说诶我一假设我做了多次采样
我喝得到很多的面对吧
或者我沿途采到了很多的点
怎么办
这里面的lumen里面的它都有很多的细节去展开
那我们这边今天不展开
但是你大家就要记住
就是处理完之后呢
我就能得到这个世界上的一个works lies的表达
那那这里面就讲了一个前后多个hit怎么办
它它是在一个44的这个town里面
这个东西是做什么的
其实我的理解就是它的空间切成很多小格子
这个格子当然比VOX要大一点
那么它吧比如说我有1000多个物体对吧
或者是1万多个instance放进去的话
那我在每一个小的tale里面这个区域
比如说34米的这个区域里面的cube里面的话
它顶多也就是七八个五六个物体
这样的话我在这样一个就是比如说呃
比如3米乘3米的这个cube里面
我去设一个瑞
只跟大概四五个物体进行求教的话
这个效率是非常非常高的
所以它的VOLATION速度也是非常快的
那么这个selection的话呢
就像我前面讲VXCI呢
它的更新也不需要每一帧全部更新对吧
它只需要每次你相机移动了
或者场景里的物体移动了
诶
我只会把弄脏的那几个地方
把它更新一下就可以了
这细节我就不展开了
但是呢他大家记住一点
就是它是用SDF的求教
快速的就得出了每一个WORKO的
第一个就是有没有东西
有东西他应该法向朝哪
它应该深度多深
然后呢他的lighting应该是怎么样的
他就这个方法就弄得落获得了那么好
当我知道了空间的这个WAKO的表达
我知道这个焦点的时候
那我怎么知道这个walkle lighting呢
哎这个时候其实就比较有意思了
它实际上呢是这个东西就是个鸡和蛋的问题了
就是说我假设把空间上的所有的表面的WORKO
全部找到了
每个WORKO有六个面对吧
我就朝外面的面有有用
朝你们那面全没有用的好
这个面我怎么知道他的生命是多少呢
诶刚才不是讲了
我有这个这个surface cash嘛对吧
那么surface cash呢回到这张图啊
我觉得这个这个要怪我时间太紧张了
没有办法讲的很清楚
但是我觉得还是要回到这张图来来来
如果对于我的第一针的时候
大家可以认为这个时候我的WORKO
那些空间上的WORKO全是黑的
你不用管他对吧
那你既然因为TF0的时候
F0-1是一帧
这一帧不存在
所以呢INDUALIGHLIGHTING也是没有的
只有direct lighting
这个时候你发现没有诶
我surface cash那个final lighting
实际上就是直接光照的结果
对吧好啦
那没关系啊
你直接光照的结果
假设我已经知道了空间上的works的表达
然后呢我又知道这个每一个WAKO的这一面
比如说比如说这个VOXEL啊
这个这个不太好
我就讲这个吧
比如说这个地方你看到大家看到这个啊
相机近点这个地方这个WAKO对吧
这个面OK我知道在那个就是surface cash里面
它对于哪个card的哪一个面的哪一个pixel
我可不可以知道
其实我甚至可以知道它的整个覆盖面积
那我怎么办
那这个WORKO的这个面的亮度
是不是可以直接取那个cash里面的值啊
这个地方到底是直接取一个点还是filtering
我已经不太记得了
但是呢啊lumen里面肯定是有办法可以取代
但是它最核心的思想就是
我用这个surface cash的final lighting的结果
去照亮我的这个WORKO的lighting
诶
好这个works the lighting呢
我把它存在
那等我下一帧去再去更新
我的这个surface cash in发达了nineteen的时候诶
我就用这种WORKALIZE的这个世界的表达
去这个帮我去做这个in det lighting
诶
而且这个时候呢我取得的东西的话
天然的就具有multi bing的结果
这个方法其实非常的巧妙啊
那但是呢实话实说他在工程上特别的复杂
而且这个这个就是works lighting呢
实际上和后面他讲的那个worst space pro
是特别特别容易混淆的
那这里面我给大家做个区分
就是说这里面的这个works lighting
它指的它的每个面
它首先是一个是一个是一个cube的六个面
而且每个面呢它只存一个亮度
啥都不存
但是呢worth后面讲的那个worth it probe
它实际上是一个空间上的光场分布
他那个作用是什么呢
那是照亮别人的
明白我的意思吧
他是照负责照亮别人的
而这个你们存的是什么呢
哎我被照得有多亮啊
这两个概念很容易混淆
但是大家没办法
我们只能够就是大家这个这个这个容忍一下
确实是很复杂
但是你确实会发现这样的一个算法
他就真的很巧妙
就是通过因为这个方法为什么好呢
大家想想看
我们rendering的话
111秒钟有30帧对吧
你这样的这个light在
如果场景的相机动得不是特别的快对吧
光动的不是特别的快
假设像很多时候我们都是相机基本固定嘛对吧
然后那个光也差不多不会太动了
但实际上不出十几针吧
你就能得到十几次boss的光的结果
这样呢这个光啊看上去它就很自然
哎这个东西为什么很重要
就是我所以我们自己还做了个实验
就是我们用lumen的效果
我们动了一下光之后
我们可以明显地感觉到那个光啊
就是它会有一个大概可能是零点几秒的感觉
那个光嗯慢慢就变亮了
其实难的就是这个works lighting
他在给你传递那种MULTIFUNCTION的那个结果对吧
这个很有意思
就是大家有机会可以看一下好
这就是我这边顺便小小的黑一下
就是我们看到很多lumen的截图的时候
他一般给你的都是一张竞争对吧
一张竞争
然后呢你看起来非常的漂亮
那张竞争你就会看着很漂亮的话
大概率是开了高配
而且呢已经炫了
大概有比如说哎这个0.5秒或者一秒之后
这个多少次BING的结果看上去非常自然
但是如果这个动画的话
比如光和相机动得非常的快的话
其实我觉得就现在的这个real time gi的技术的话
都还是蛮挑战的
OK好
这就是我们的整个light cashing的pipeline
它最核心的就是让我们怎么解决
就是说我的光源怎么来
就是我要算基
我要知道空间上无数的光源
那这些光源呢
我就用通过这个方法把它cashing到我的surface cash
其实我的surface cash1套之后呢
我又用surface cash还在一个WORKALIZE世界的表达
你又做了一套这个东西
不仅是说A帮我去更新
诶
不好意思啊
我这个PPT写的我还要再优化一下
时间实在太紧张了
就是它不仅是帮我们去算那个surface cash的那个
Final lighting
其实这个workspace works lighting的话
在我后面的那个problem里面也是有用的
为什么呢
刚才我讲到一个细节了
就是说当我一根锐射出去之后
如果我没有办法用那个就是PROMESH的STF
我必须要用global s t f的话
刚才讲过global s t f的问题是什么
就是他拿不到你到底诶
稍等是这个这意思
他拿不到
就是说那个你到底hit重了
是哪个instance也拿不到他
你更拿不到你hit动作是哪个面
那个那个面上的他的一切信息都拿不到
所以呢这个时候你只能在global的这个works lighting里面
去找到它的lighting
所以这个数据就是一套一套对应好的
哎呀我我现在已经突然想起来
这个突然想出来这个PPT怎么画了
他真的就是数据是一套一套对应好的
就放在这
那么这一趴呢我就不再讲的足够太深了
就不展开
但是呢大家理解一下
就是说他用一个就是说啊surface cash对吧
把整个空间把整个场景表达成一个个的六面
六个面的那个剪影
就相当于说我本来本来一个人的物体诶
我用六个平板把它罩起来
你们知道在那个呃在做LD的时候吧
有一个叫impose技术点吧
就是说诶我一个远处的物体
我用几个面表达成IMPOSTER
就大概能表达它的样子
其实你可以认为那个surface cash
看你那个mesh car的技术的话
其实很像这个一个为lighting准备的这个IMPOSTER
那么好
我又不是所有的物体都能用impostor去表达lighting
也不是所谓letting impossible impose表达
我同时呢要做multi bouncing the global nation
那怎么办呢
诶他想到了一个方法
就是说我把空间整个把你这个这个哎呀
这个PPT真的要优化一下
那个就是把你空间整个给你WORKALIZATION
就变成一个表达一个一个更加粗的
但是呢它能表达几百米范围之内的
这样的一个场景的
这个这个这个lighting的这个信息
你无论是近处的promise的表达
还是远处的整个场景
大致看看它的亮度的话
其实都可以表达
这里面其实还有个细节
我们今天没有展开
比如说有些比较复杂的东西
比如说terrain对吧
terrain你肯定不能用match cut cut cut cut去表达
那你怎么办
诶terrain他还得单独处理
其实lumen里面还有很多的细节
比如说啊我这边在市面荡开一笔
比如说你中间假设有一些participate media
半透明的一团雾对吧
那它的光照怎么算
哎这里面有无数的细节了
对不对
那我作为一系列的课程也就不展开了
反正这里面坑特别多
所以我觉得这个作者还是非常的了不起啊
就是真的把这个技术工程化了
因为全局光照real time real globe dation
而且PDNCALIZE
它真的就是一个非常非常复杂的一个问题
那么他基本上用了这样的一个方法
然后呢能能踩到cashing了所有的radio
那这个时候呢我就比较简单了
对于每一个这个surface cash的东西呢
他呢说那我既然你对这个世界有这样的表达
我就知道怎么去sample你的in your lighting了
他的算法是写死了的
我记得我如果没记错的话
我们呢是这样写死的
就是说哎对于surface cash上每88
它定义成一个TL
注意啊
就lumen in的名词真的是从用率特别高
这个tile这个词在各种地方都有用过
而且每个地方的tell
它表达的意思都是不一样的
所以这个地方的tale指的就是在surface cash里面
他选择88的这个text
然后呢它采四个样
这四个样呢实际上是在你们JERING的对吧
然后呢他设了16根锐射出去
这个瑞呢跟谁求交呢
哎跟那个WORKO
你空间上的WORKO表达进入注意啊
就是surface cash不会用自己去做intern lighting
他永远是在那个啊WORKO上面
就是那个worko lighting上去取
他的那个就是那个结果
然后呢诶我就可以获得这样的一个intro lighting
他把这个intro lighting呢存成什么呢
存成了一个就是这个sofil harmonics
那为什么除了存在SURFHONEX呢
大家想想看啊
就是我这个空间上这些数据
我真正在shading surface cash上的每一个pixel的时候
哎你看这里面这张图
你们可以看到就是它是8×8
里面有64个点对吧
它只有四个采样
所以对于每个点来讲的话呢
他要找相邻的四个点去插值
那差值最方便的是什么呢
用SHCOFM去差值
大家仔细推推导一下
就知道这里面还是很巧妙的一个一个变化
我有了这个差值玩的SH的表达的话
我是不是就可以可以算出来
说这个球面上的间接
这个INTERFLIGHTING对我的shading的结果
实际上我这个时候我的结果上就会加上一层
这个就是dua lighting的结果
那这张图上呢
就是你可以看到就是这边亮的是它直接光照
对吧
那个intro lighting是在间接光照
这里面
其实那个直接光照它是HDR的
所以你看上去它会偏亮
但是实际上的话呢它这些亮度差得很大
然后最后合到一起
你可以形成一个你想要的final
结果这个图本身做的呢我觉得不是特别好
但也没办法
因为呃原作者没有提供比较好图
所以我们只能在unreal里面自己写代码
这个东西抠出来了
后面我们有时间的话
我们会扣得更好一点
但是呢这些东西的话
实际上是啊
我们真的是从代码中深抠出来的东西
对吧对吧
大家原谅一下
那么其实的话呢
这样两个lighting就可以结合在一起
形成我们想要的这样的一个multiple lighting
而且这里面为什么这个方法非常巧妙呢
就是说其实真实的游戏场景非常的复杂
他用了这样的一个surface cash的这个思路啊
他还把有一个很难的问题给解决掉了
就是自发光
哎大家如果在这个做游戏的时候
其实自发光这件事情是真的很难
为什么呢
自发光这件事情如果你只考虑它本身变量的话
那很简单
在最终颜色上硬生生的加上去一个光
对不对
但是我们设想中的自发光是什么效果
比如说哎我这个武士这边有一条灯带
很帅对不对
但你旁边假设我靠近了一个墙
这边假设有一堵墙啊
你希望这个蓝色的光
是不是能把墙稍微硬亮一点点对吧
我甚至还希望有那么一点点软阴影的效果
那这个怎么解啊
这个其实非常的难啊
因为你知道在游戏里面
我们处理一个光源原始的做法
我觉得渲渲染一次对吧
我最让我们在前面人队里讲了很多方法
能解决MTILISOURCE的问题
但是我这是一条光带啊
大哥我这个很难是一条光带
我怎么去渲染它
诶
他用这个就是这个surface cash的方法的话
其实即使是一个光带
我实际上也能够把它整体的cash到我的这个
这个这个就是lighting里面去
我在第一帧的时候
这个光带不起作用
对不对
但是呢我通过这个左脚踩右脚
我把它三零到我的WORKO的那个light space里面去
诶我下一针就把它给卷回来了
诶再卷两次
卷一次
卷两次
你就能看到那个墙那个地方就会被照亮了
这个地方
其实我个人觉得还是非常非常的巧妙的
所以surface action说句实话
我乍一看的时候
我我我我我喷了很久
我说好麻烦啊
为什么我要给每个mesh还踩六个面
这个好蠢啊
因为呃呃不好意思
不能说脏话
就是这个这个反正我就觉得好麻烦对吧
很很很很
你还要去做atlas还是做packing
还要做这个那个内存的分配啊
想想头都疼对吧
我以前特别不喜欢
就是实现那个virtual texture那个算法
因为就觉得特别麻烦
而且特别容易写出bug
但是呢你仔细想仔细想仔细想
你发现哇这个方法还是很有道理的好
那这个就是其实呢这个地方
我觉得那个mesh cashing啊
包括那个works workitty啊
其实他都符合刚才我讲的SDF的一个设计思想
就是说我把一个irregular的东西
就是你想在世界里面的这些物体的表达
非常的复杂
对不对
我用mesh cashing
用用match card
用surface cashing
再加上works lighting的话
把它变成了一个uniform的regular的表达
那我接下来无论是做他任何的一个积分也好
这个卷积也好
采样也好
都会变得更加的简单
你看这个采样采样采样
这个时候采样的基础是什么
是数学的表达
对吧
我我所以说我觉得学完104的同学的话
我觉得大家会非常有兴趣
回去学一些什么信号处理啊
什么什么这个这个理这个这个局
那个应该是那个呃应该是线性代数
大家肯定要好好去学的对吧
包括一些几何的一些东西
包括一些比如说像一些数分啊
一些高等代数的东西
大家都会想学
因为这些东西真的是密切关联的
对于我们来讲好补水了
我们继续往下讲
我们已经讲了两个小时
20分钟
预计今天要三小时起飞了
好其实呢就是对于整个这个surface cash啊
他的这个更新还是挺废的
所以在lumen里面他做了一个bug
他就说哎我每一帧的话对
直接光照我最多不超过
我不是40996×4096吗
每一帧的时候唉
我最多不超过1024×24个
TEXO更新对吧
那么for intro lighting呢
因为大家知道间接光照更新起来
其实还是很废的
因为他要在那个很多的那个这个WORKLIES的
这个世界上去采样
对不对
虽然我讲了基于SDF的采样效率很高的
基于GLOBUSDF是更快了
但是它本身还是挺废的
那怎么办呢
他说诶我每次最多更新512512texture
所以对于每一个mash card来讲
它都要排排队
说哎我也想更新
我也想更新
那他就要设置一个priority
去进行这种这个去去去管理它
然后呢去选择更新
所以呢这里面其实有一些一整套的
比较复杂的排队算法
还有bucket salt这个算法
但这个算法的细节我已经就不展开了
因为有兴趣的同学可以去看它
但是你只要和就这一趴lumen
大家就知道了
光到底是怎么设计呢
且在这个世界里面我把它抓住的
对这个就是我先讲叫freeze
你把这光抓住
就像我
大家也就我又要再提我心爱的phont mapping了
就是phont map里面
最后我要把这些光子
把它固定在这个mesh的表面
我只要把你这光子固定住了
接下来我就可以做CD了
好
那接下来呢
我们现在只是把这个shading cash住了
那接下来我们要干什么呢
哎我现在虽然知道了这些光子在物体的表面
但是当我一个做shading的时候
实际上我知道比如说这个mesh的这个表面的
它自己的亮度
它的照度对吧
其实并不能作为我任何一个mesh
就是任何一个像素设定的基础
我得把对于一个对于一个呃屏幕上的像素而言
我老师指着自己的身体
我现在变成了一个rendering object了
对吧好
那比如我要渲染这块好
那我呢是要把我周围半球面的
所有的radiance全部拿到
我要得到一个什么东西呢
叫prom a对吧
搞了这么多
其实你这个光照
就是你这个地方还没有办法渲染
因为你只是知道说比如说我面前的这个灯
比如说这边有个灯对吧
我放到这边来这个灯啊
这这个mesh
比如它它的各个各个点的照度是多少
这个我这只手的照度多少
当我要训练这个肩膀的时候
诶
我要把这些这个radios全部变成一个proper的表达
所以接下来硬核的东西来了
我怎么去分布这些prop
然后呢对于每一个屏幕上的点
我到底怎么用probe去这个这个这个lighting
所以呢它的第三排也是这个lumen讲lumen的时候
特别容易上来就讲了东西
就是说我在screen space怎么去分布这些prop
并且能采样到我要的东西
那其实呢他又在worst space做了一些prop采样
所以他搞了两种以上的prop
这样让你能够永远的踩到东西
所以这是我们的第三方
但那第四趴那就讲了什么呢
我竟然有了这么多的prop对吧
那好我拿到一个screen speed pixel
我怎么去用这些prop做shading
基本上讲到这一趴
整个lumen就讲完了
好我们到第3part了
也就是lumen的这个经常提的一个东西
就是这个screen space part
在屏幕上的part
这里面呢其实它的基础的idea
我个人觉得还是非常非常巧妙的
因为啊就是我我我想起来了
今天我还有一有1part没有讲
叫dd j i对吧
diffuse这个dynamic
diffuse global innovation对吧
还有最新的一些国内的工作
就SDFDDGI对吧
这些工作其实啊problem这个东西呢
你最自然的一个想法是什么呢
在空间上均匀分布
我撒无数个采样点
然后呢
用那个点对一个球面空间的光照进行采样
因为我既然已经得到了一个surface cash
我又得到了一个WORKO的这个这个
这个surface的这个lighting the cash
其实我去构建这个prop是可以的
但是呢当我真的去渲染一个场景的时候
场景里面他的这个起伏是非常非常多的
那你的pp怎么分布呢
靠近camera
我放的密一点
离开camera放的远一点
可以的
但是呢当我出现了一个几何结构出来之后
你比如说1米1米
一米隔一米放一个problem的话
实际上它并不能保证
你真的能够表达广场的变化
但这个变化如果你表达不了的话
实际上你照出来的东西看上去就很怪
就是我们经常用一句行话讲
就是看上去很平哎
这是所有的
就是如果预先生成好的这个proper displacement的话
他都会有这个proper distribution都会产生的问题
而lumen呢他就比较大胆
他说我就在screen space打prop对
很粗暴
意思就是说我狠一点的话
我屏幕上的每个像素点
我对它进行整个球面的广场的这个pro采样
那我选出来了一定是对的对吧
但是呢他还没有那么粗暴
因为如果每个像素点都去踩一个的话
那实在是太疯狂了
他就说那我还是悠着点
我每隔1616个pixel诶
我踩一个screen space的这个problem
这个为什么16×16这个事情有道理呢
其实很简单
就是说啊你相机看的话
如果离你近的地方
1616个pixel啊
它其实在空间上的距离不会太远
而间接光照呢这个东西它是个低频的东西
所以呢你在这么近的距离里面
它的virus其实确实不会很大
那么它高频的东西呢
就像我前面讲过
就是它可以用那个表面自己的
这个就是说法线啊
这些材质的细节可以表达出来
所以低频的光照间接光照它可以直接上采样
而且它每个prop的采样呢
它采了两个数据
第一个当然是radius了
其实呢还包括了一个hit distance
那他对这个东西的
就是他怎么去存储这个problem呢
这里面一个细节就是用就是那个就是啊叫啊
OCITRON那个main
这个mapping呢
实际上是参数化里面一个非常经典的一个mapping
就是这个这个map
如果同学们在做任何的GI算法
包括采样算法
我会建议大家去研究一下
其实它很简单
就是说我们在在图形学里面经常遇到一个问题
就是在球面上撒采样点对吧
那最简单的采样是什么呢
经纬度采样对不对
经纬度采样呢
如果你把它映射到一个2D的texture
它会出一个问题
就是说天顶它采样密度特别高
靠近赤道采样率都很低
那大家一直希望一个分布相对均匀的采样
但是呢它这个采样还有一个特点
就是我给你任何一个一个一个就是一个方向
我能迅速地知道它的UV空间的位置
那这个数学上他就要求一个是连续的
一个要非常简单
而这个八面体的这个球面映射呢
他就满足这个特点
第一个它的任何一个方向映射到2D的UI
计算非常简单
就是下面这个SHADER
同时呢它可以进行BINARINTERLATION
因为你相邻的两个TXT之间的采样点的采样
在纹理空间的差值
基本上逼近于在球面上的差值
所以它是一个非常好的参数化
所以这样的好处就是说诶
我可以用一个不多的采样点
相对均匀地分布在球面上
那么在这个就是crispace prop里面的话呢
他用的这个采样精度是8×8
也就是说对于整个球面空间的话
哎我上面这个方向大概才四个
下面这个方向才八个
这个方向要踩八个
诶
我大致均匀的分
当然这个不是严格的大致均匀
这样去分布了好
那么然后呢他有一个非常有意思的思想
就是说那我每隔16个screen pixel
我做一次采样
但是呢如果你在这个screen里面
因为我有depth
我就知道你这个彼此之间
在真实的物理世界的距离有多大对吧
worst page距离有多大
如果你两个相差特别大
比如说朝向一看
我就知道你们俩根本不共面的
对不对
比如说虽然这个在视觉上投影上
就是在相机位置
你看上去很相邻的两个pixel
在在真实的物理空间上距离非常远
那怎么办
那你1616个text采样
它其实是有问题的
如果你强行的这么干的话呢
你就会把很多光照的细节模糊化掉了
这个东西怎么去理解呢
我记得在天文学上有一个概念叫做试灵心
大家有没有听说过
就讲的是两颗恒星
你看上去很近对吧
好像谁相伴的谁
比如小时候我们去听神话故事说
诶这个食指两颗恒星在一起
什么北斗七星啊
我们在一起什么在一起
但实际上天文学老师
天文学家会告诉你说
他只是在试在视觉上看上去很近
但实际上他们真正的距离非常远
为什么呢
他们的深度值是不一样的对吧
他们很可能相聚了是几百甚至上千公里光年
对吧
那实际上呢在这个lumen screen space
这个我的这个低度采样的时候
就会出现这种情况
那我就需要有一个方法
就是说如果我发现啊
我在这个16×16的这个采样区域里面
它其实很多点之间的这个距离
在真实距离非常远的时候
我认为这个采样精度不够
那我怎么办呢
我去refine
我把它藏密度在那个在那个grade里面
我把它再增加一倍
变成8×8
8×8不够怎么办
我再给他refine一下
我变成4×4
这个听上去就很神奇了吧对吧
那怎么知道这个东西我要去refine它呢
诶它是基于一个基础的假设
就是一个有效的差值
这个有票的差值怎么去定义呢
就是说想象一下啊
我对于一个16×16的这个这个
这个这个这个这个一个tile
就是我一个spring weet prop所取得这个区域
假设我任何一个pixel我要去渲染的时候
我要设定的时候
我要从这四个problem这个采样
就是那个从我临近的四个probe之间去取取
它的差值
我这里面的取
比如说取16个或者取32个点
我去采样的时候呢
我这个点呢其实除了我自己的空间位置之外
还有什么呢
还有我的法向
我就会得到一个平面
我把你这四个prop的中心点投影到我的平面上
我去看你的投影距离的权重
诶
这个时候作者就开发了一个非常high的一个函数
大家看到了
这里面就说诶
我距离的平均相机到那个点的距离
还有他要乘上一个这个到ex f的那个
就是那个ex p就是他的那个多少次幂对吧
还给了一些很牛逼的一些常数放在一起
然后呢他说你这个error只要累计大于某一个press hold
我就认为这个采样点是不能用了
如果我这些采样点足够多的不能用的话
我认为就是你这四个采样点对我是无效的
这个思想就是在基于我的这个点的法平面
去做投影距离进行插值
包括我的空间距离差值啊
这个思想其实啊如果我没记错
好像是在那个r seven里面
还是在那个就是啊WAI里面都用过这个思想
就这个思想其实是被证明了
是个很有用的一个思想
因为这个思想的话呢
其实哦哎好像是S级里面用了也用了这个思想
就是说这样我就可以就是避免
就是我的采样是无效的采样
为什么呢
因为我相邻的两个pixel之间相距
可能会在真实世界里相距可能会非常远
对不对
那么同样你踩过来的这些
这个这个这个就是props
它在物理空间的位置可能是非常的远
那对于我这个点所设定的时候
如果我用了你这个pro实际上就是无效的
当我这种无效率大了足够多的时候
那我认为这个采样就是不够的
所以呢我就要申请
你把这个tile再给我去细分一下诶
我再去采用一个额外的pro这种adaptive sampling
实际上是这个lumen
我认为是一个非常聪明的一个做法
因为这个方法你听上去可能非常的复杂
但实际上呢
他对存储空间的消耗并没有大家想象的那么大
为什么呢
他把screen space所有的prop做了一个APOL
那大家想想看啊
我们做texture uv的时候
一般是不是一个方形texture对吧
但是呢我们在绘制的时候
屏幕一般是什么样子的
一般是一个长条形
那好那假设我屏幕上的pixel都是1616的
你们发现没有
我把这个prop就是每个prop是个88嘛
我就占用88的那个那个那个text
我当当当当存进去的时候
你发现没有
下面正好有一节空间是没有用的
对不对
诶
他的聪明的地方就来了
他把你这些需要refined的这些problem
我就把它packing在它的下面
反正我就存个index就好了嘛
就相当于我每个spring pop我会存一个值
说哎我这个problem有没有被refine
如果有被refine
你你的位移应该在哪里诶
我就把它存在
那同样的
我你我找到这个如果是L0的这个problem
觉得这个反过来就D最大最粗的那层problem
找下去发现它需要一放
我就找到往下一层
哎
往下那个project又存了
说哎你还可以再往下走
所以你看他其实没有用多少额外的存储空间
因为你text分配的时候
反正是个方形
放在那下面的地方我都用起来了
但是呢哎我就可以对我的视空间的这些
这个这个这个lighting的信息啊
进行了一个什么呢
叫做adaptive sampling
自适应的一个采样
这个对这个rendering来讲其实非常的重要
这个我个人觉得是lumen非常巧妙的一个想法
哎我我我们在分析前面的工作的时候
好像这还是第一个提出来
用screen space的方法去这个进行这个radiance采样
而且他他还搞了一个这个adaptive
才这样的话就避免了
就是以前我们讲这个比如说啊VXCI啊
我们讲的这个就是那个R3嘛
这些东西
它其实你本质上它都是UI风的采样对吧
像r seven里面的话
它其实已经有一点点adapt的思想
大家还记得r r seven里面有那些红色的pixel吗
他觉得不够怎么办
哎我还在对他进行采样
其实呢在这个lumen里面的话
screen space prop的话呢
它的这一套adapt to something
我个人觉得还是非常精彩的一个想法
对
其实我为什么这么有兴趣
给大家去把鲁曼讲清楚呢
我个人觉得就是说
lumen其实是一个非常具有启发性的
一个算法体系
就这里面的很多算法你不止可以用在GI上面
你肯定会用在一些你其他要用的rendering上面
好
OK那这个地方我就讲到这儿了
好那这里面呢就是这个是我们课程组啊
土法炼钢的一个一张图啊
如果大家一定要这个原谅我们的粗糙
那么但是呢虽然粗糙
但是我们的结果非常的真诚
就在这张图上
大家可以看到
就是我们是把lumen的这个QUEPROM打印出来了
你可以看到那种啊应该是黄色的区域吧
哦应该是红色的区域
暗红色的点是1616的resolution
而那个黄色的呢就是这个啊
8×8或者4×4的
为什么8×8和44没有做区分呢
代码要改的数量地方太多了
我们就懒得改了
所以我们就偷个懒
就是把8×84乘四就统一标记出来
就告诉大家那个地方被refine
大家可以看到
就是说所有被refine的地方的话都是几何
他这个就是变worries比较大的地方对吧
这个也是很直观的看到了
其实说实话
我我们看了几乎所有的lumen的这个这个presentation
那大家能看懂的话还是蛮挑战的
OK好那就是就是说这是我们突法炼钢的一张图
OK好
那其实我们在进行这个crisped prop
采样的时候呢
其实我们用了JERING对吧
那接触的原因是什么呢
就是防止这个东西看上去太repeat啦
或者过度太太太太高了
但是呢当你有多少次多次接触你的结果的话
那实际上它在时序上又变成了一次这个multi bing
这个采样诶
这个其实也是我们在这个我们最早最早讲那个
按ta类型的ta啊
讲到这个
其实像那个SGI里面
也都用了这样的一个技术
就是我要不停的接触我的采样
但这个就是一个很细节的东西
我们就不展开了
好那这个时候就来了
我们最痛苦的东西了
我们已经大概知道我们怎么去分布
我们的problem了
那我们就要去采样了呀
采样怎么办
我们不是说8×8嘛
对不对
那我就我就往球面上8×8的这个
参数化方向去采样就完事了呀
但是呢这个对于真正的RENEE来讲
肯定是有问题的
为什么呢
因为窗户在哪里
我不知道对吧
我在一个房间里
我的英doc里面窗户在哪是一个很重要的问题
因为我的采样
如果不是使劲地朝着窗户那个方向去踩的话
相信我任何GI的算法算出来的结果
都是像那个怎么说呢
就是像是那个秃头般一样的
就是七七黑一块白一块
非常丑
哎所以接下来一个很重要的东西
就是我怎么进行important sampling好
那这个大家看到了
就假设我们不做这个important3330的话
我们看到了lighting的结果大概是这个样子的对吧
但是我这个因为这是原作者提供了一个图嘛
他到底开了哪些上网没看到
我们也不是特别清楚
但是很显然他在讲就是没有input30
我们会怎么样好
但这里面的话呢最重要的一件事情是什么呢
就是找窗户
就是我要尽可能往窗户的那个方向多设一些锐
对吧
这个其他的地方无关紧
要是能少设一点
就少设一点
哎这就是GI的妙处
就是你需要environment advance
环境感知啊
这个听下来很高大上
对不对
那但是呢其实我们的render里面很土好
那实际上呢我怎么在进行这个important呢
我们可以看到就是这个lighting函数啊
它本质上是一个一蒙特卡罗retracing对吧
蒙特author蒙特卡罗这个这个integration对啊
下面的这个概率函数呢
它的我要尽可能让我的这个概率函数
符合上面这个函数的分布
那上面这个函数呢是两个函数的积
一个是光
一个是什么呢
一个是我表面的BRDFA
这就是找到这个问题的因子了
第一个你需要知道光在哪强对吧
第二个你还知道什么呢
我的法相在哪
我的法向在哪
就告诉我说哪些东西对我来讲可能重要一点
因为你就算光在这儿
我的法相在这
那你我你就光对我有什么意义呢
对不对
我我其实是我是背对你的
我可能要更多的要踩一下背面的光对吧
所以这件事情就比较复杂了
没有那么简单好
那怎么做呢
那首先我们先怎么去鼓激光诶
这里面lumen就有一个很巧妙的思想
他说呢
哎呀我当前帧我想知道光亮的地方在哪儿
这个哎呀
不好意思
我打的是英文
打错了
待会我们负责在这个今天真的是火线赶出来的
这个这真的是这这一这一页
可能是上线之前不到半小时吧
我在这疯狂的在那手打的应该叫approximate
gradient importance from the last frame props对吧
大家原谅我这个英文的type
但是它实际上讲的是什么呢
哎很聪明
我我既然想知道光在哪怎么办
我把上一帧的problem踩一遍吧
也就是说我并不知道这一帧的光在哪
但是我做一个假设
就是光的变化没有那么快
那我从上一帧的这个这个prop里面的话
我去从最近的上一段的screen space prom里面
我去做一个采样
就是把它们的值积在一起
合在一起
我就大概知道哪个地方亮
哪个地方不按
那怎么知道呢
其实很简单
就是说哎你不是什么SH啊
或者什么东西啊
哎我把这四个指路性价值
我一样可以得到一个8×8的
这个明暗相间的这个图
这个图中亮的地方就是光比较亮的地方
就是相当于是在我这个位置
我大概猜测天会亮在哪儿对吧
所以这个last frame其实在GI里面是非常有用的
就上一帧的数据千万别丢
它有很多妙用
哎这就是他用的第一个方法
就是我去估计一下好
第二个方法呢
唉我这个方罗姆
那normal大家天然的想到
就是说哎对于我这个problem
我不是知道我这个pixel是哪嘛对吧
就算你JERING
我一定JERING在一个点上
那我的normal实际上的话就有明确的方向
那我就沿着normal做一个cos nope对吧
那下面的半个那个就是区域肯定是黑的嘛
这个听上去是不是很合理啊
很科学合理啊
哎但是这里面有一个很大的错误是什么呢
因为你在FRAMEBUFFER里面拿到的那个normal
是一个像素的normal
那个normal是非常非常高频的
大家想象一下
如果我下面的max是用nut做的哇
那个细节不要太多啊
但是我对于一个比如说啊一个小区域而言
那你们可能cover了
比如说32×32
1000多个pixel
如果更大一点
有更多的pixel对吧
那1000多个皮索的真正的它的大致的法向朝向
并不能由我这一个单独的这个采样点的法向
所代表大家思想是不是这样的
那如果我这个时候去在这个位置去做一个light
prop的时候
我是不是要考虑我周边所有的诶几何的
就是screen space连接的这个几何的
它的normal的朝向是这样的
他所以呢他是个什么呢
它是个distribution
唉
它不是一个单一的一个normal的点
这个地方是特别特别容易弄混的
那他怎么做呢
他这时候就想到了一件事
就是说我在做shading的时候
哎我其实肯定large bob是要插值的嘛
对不对
他就想了个办法
他呢就是在大概这个32×32的
这个范围里面
32×32什么概念
我不是一个一个一个TOL
是16×16吗
为什么三十二十三二
因为你对这个screen space进行by inia
TEMPLATION的时候
你会发现你的一个prop的值最多会影响哎
离你最远32个pixel的值
大家想象一下
就是两个两个之间连接
是不是这样的
对吧好
那我在这个3232里面有多少个pixel呢
1024个pixel
那我把1024个pixel的normal的
所引发的这个distribution function全部加在一起
我是不是要疯掉了
对不对
这个就要死了
那怎么办呢
哎我认64个点去载你们去采样
你看各种hack啊
而且这个采样呢它还不是一个简单的
就是说我把我就在周围
32×32的区间里面
我就随机砸了64个点
没有他呢还要去做一个什么呢
Death's weet
就确保我们的depth彼彼此之间
因为我知道我这个prop这个点在哪里嘛
就是你们我们的DESWEET在我的投影平面上
彼此相差不要太大
这里面有一整套的这个数学的这个古籍
它简单的讲就是说你的投影距离我太远
法向这个就是那个距离我太远的地方
我全部给你扔掉一堆的hack
然后呢我把这些normal的每个normal
它其实每个normal的importance是不是个cos loop
对不对
每个cos lol是不是就一个SH对吧
我把这些SH全部积分在一起诶
最后我才可以得到一个什么呢
norm的这个diribution function
那我有了这样的一个东西的时候呢
哎我大概就知道哪些区域从normal上看
哪些方向
从NO more上看
我需要重点的去采样
我就得到一个BTF了
好
那接下来呢我们要做一个很有意思的这个
这一页我发的有点早了啊
这个normal视频function
因为这个原图上也讲的不是很清楚
就在讲到下下一页的时候会讲的比较清楚
那我下一页跟他讲
这个里面呢它就有一个非常巧妙的一个想法
他说啊对于每一个就是screen space prop
我最多呢还是只采样64个
为什么呢
因为我硬件那么多的prop对吧
虽然说我是16×16
但实际上呃我还是有
大概我想想可能要将近上万个吧
还赚十几万个prop对吧
每个prop要设设那么多的锐的话
实际上现代硬件也是扛不住的
他他就给了一个想法
就是说我能不能够在我需要采样的地方
采样加密一点
比如说这个这个方向它很重要
我做设四根采样锐主曲
但是呢我存储的时候呢
我还是把它们合到一起
存一个存成一个TXT
因为就相当于说大家想一下这个
这当然是一个这个这个最早的思想
其实在摩托卡老师内里面就有了
就是说我在做这个retesting的时候呢
那个地方
我因为发现那个地方可能光源很小很密
我会把这个地方射线射的密一点
但是呢最后我在做shading的时候呢
我可以把这些射线所有的结果
因为他们彼此的角度很接近嘛
所以我可以把它合到一起的
就是做设定的时候
我们并不需要做那么多次的这个这个累加对吧
所以的话呢我要保证总的采样次数不变
但是呢我要有他的importance诶
这个时候就有一个他一个非常巧妙的一个算法
这个标题是我自己写的
就是说它实际上是说我所有采样的数量
设得瑞的数量是不变的
所有的这个pro都是64根尾射出去
但是呢我算出来了
你的这个BRDF
就是你的法向所这个所提供的这个这个这个PDF
也就是你的importance function对吧
和你的lighting
lighting是从上一帧抠下来的
你的important function
我把这两个诶一卷积在一起
我觉得到了哪些点是重要的
哪一点不重要的
那我这时候呢有64×64个点
我怎么做呢
哎我对这个点进行排序
我这样一排序我就知道什么呢
就是最不重要的那些那些那些方向
和最重要的那些方向
那我呢设置一个阈值
我就从最不重要的方向1231次走
当我找到三个
就是倒数前第三个
前三个
这个就是最不重要的方向
当然假设他们的这个PDF值
都小于我的阈值的时候
就意味着什么呢
我那个最需要采样的那个方向
我可以对它进行一次super sampling
为什么呢
因为本来只能采样一次
我给你再加三次的话
你不就四次了
四次就意味着什么
意味着你就可以进行一次refined
sampling的对吧
那以此类推
就是说我通过这个PDF的值
我把你最不重要的方向全部过滤掉
然后呢
让我的采样尽量集中在这个很重要的方向
这个方向可能来自于你的法向
朝那个法向的分布
也可能来自于光源
诶
这个地方其实是非常的巧妙
就是64根瑞
这也是lumen我认为非常巧妙的
很实战化的一个东西
因为这样就让我的硬件的时间
成本就可以算出来了
这样的话你看这里面就一张图
就是这个acs pro
它的光线
你会发现它就会集中在墙上相对比较亮的地方
那这样的话
它整个这个rendering的结果就会好很多
那就是你有这个就是啊fix bug这样的
Adaptive sampling
就基于这个光墙
基于你个normal的方向和没有的话
他两个的noise真的是不一样的
但是它它有很多前后的对比
其实你根本不知道这些东西
比如说因为它有很多种field dream dnose的方法
每一次你看了都说哦这个东西上去很重要
但是后面一个图的时候
他又说又很重要
但是你不知道这一层层的怎么样
所以后面等我们有时间的话呢
我们把东西实现的时候一步步的看
大家可以看得更清楚一点
OK好
那么同样这个结果也是这样
前面的话他没有做这个important sampling对吧
后面这个光方向做了important
important sampling的时候
他很显然这个场景你们看到都有共同的特点
是什么
都是室内诶
都是有一张窗子对吧
窗子就是我们的GI的一生之敌
那么有一扇窗子
那这个时候呢哎我们这看到就是你有import sample
我对光的采样就会好很多
那我这样的一个积压的效果就会稳定
非常的多好
那有了这样的东西的时候够不够还是不够
你看我们这边又来了
我们要降噪
我们要进行这个过滤
进行filtering
那么只要你做CI这个FILIN
就是你逃不掉的东西好
那它怎么做filtering呢
其实是这样的
就是其实按1616的这个screen space
这个这个TOL去做的problem
它采出来的信息其实还是非常非常不稳定的
有很多的noise
那怎么办呢
他每一个prop我在旁边找
临近的这样的一个一圈对吧
他一般讲33这个kernel
我把周边的prop的这个光线
我把它filter出来
但是这个proper之间的fil train啊
就比大家想象的要复杂了
这里面的大家想想看
我每个prop我是射出去了什么呢
我设置了64根啊
68乘八六十四根锐对吧
那我旁边那个prop我是把那个锐就是同方向的
我就直接把它给加到一起
这样对不对呢
哎其实是不对的
为什么呢
因为我旁边那个problem距离我不是一个距离吗
那他呢很可能他测的那根锐啊
他射到的这个物体离我非常的近对吧
他呢那个东西呢其实在我的这个prop里面
他我看过去的角的射线角度是完全不一样的
这里面举个例子
就是前面有个有一个反射物在我的球在我前面
注意啊
他不知道他是反射物啊
然后说不定光源在头顶上照下来
所以那个那个面罩的非常亮
我这个light probe一定要踩踏了
对不对
那我我取得我的NEIGHBORNPM呢
他那根锐其实是方向是朝下的
但是呢我如果把那个瑞直接用到我上面的话
那我会发现他彻底用错了
为什么呢
因为对于我这个problem来讲的话呢
它的方向是从上面过来的
所以呢当我去加权这些re的时候
我是要看你的方向
如果你的方向跟我不一致的话
我认为这跟ray就这个方向是一个不一致的差值
哎你发现没有
这个for循环很好玩
他写的是说我所有的neighbor prop的
所有的R我都要做一次可用性的一个检测
比如说这里面它就hard code的一个
这个是我们放代码翻出来的
他写的是说如果这个夹角超过了十度
我就不用了
这个RIO
你这差十哥们
我就不用你了
我只相信我自己
不相信你
OK那好
那如果呢呃呃如果这个东西不处理
你看到这里面就有这个error了
大家看见没有
就是说这个墙上会有很多的noise
就是因为他在临近会踩错很多东西
好这个听上去很有道理对吧
但这个呢就又产生了另外一个问题了
假设我邻居的那个瑞啊
他其实射的是非常非常的远
你把那个远处的那个焦点拉回来
这个角度呢也是对的
也没问题
对不对
但是呢你去看你自己
你发现你自己发出来同样一个角度测试光线
你射到的距离其实很近的
所以你们两个锐之间
就是蓝色的和绿色那根线的夹角
虽然小于你的十个度的这个press hold
但是呢你很明显
你的hit distance和他的his distance有很大的差距
那你又在哈克的一把说
不好意思
虽然我们俩的夹角对吧
看起来好像那么的接近
但是呢你好像是在100米之外打中了一个东西
但是呢我自己在同一个方向测试
我发现我在5米之外我就被拦住了
所以你那个踩出来了
那个那个radio大概率是对我是无效的
那不好意思
我还是用我自己的诶
这个地方它又能解决这个问题
因为他这个你不解决的话呢
它就会出现这种漏光的问题
比如像这点这个case里面
你发现那个毛巾的这个内侧面
它跟靠墙的那个地方诶
如果你生硬的不考虑这个差值呢
它就会发白很多
光漏进来了
被插值插进来了
但是呢如果你考虑这个问题的时候
你会发现诶它这个光也开始变得比较有道理了
怎么样
无数的骇客啊
对
所以它这里面光的差值就是prop之间
光的差值是非常讲究的好
那整个在一起的话
你就会看到这个结果就会好很多对吧
所以lumen是一个
我个人觉得还是非常实战的一个技术
就是他的每一个细节考虑的
真的是我用一个词形容叫什么呢
叫周到得非常的周到
哈哈OK好
那接下来的话呢就是说诶
我们虽然在screen space里面可以做这么多的prop
但这个prop第一个数量非常大
第二个的话呢它这个是就是shading呢
他跑的太远
其实它的效率并不高
那lumen呢又想了一个办法
他说我呢就是在这个screen sweet pop
你就去找一些周边的东西了好吧
但是呢对于非常远的东西
其实呢你会发现他那个方向啊就射得远之后
他基本上大差不离的对吧
你每如果每一个scrsweet pop
每个ray都跑了那么远
其实你的效率是很低的
但这里面讲一个细节
就是说我们经常讲硬件的hardware retracing对吧
其实retracing呢
它的性能不止受这个你设了多少个瑞的影响
其实还受什么的
你的场景复杂度的影响
场景复杂度的影响之外呢
还影响什么
你这个锐到底跑多远
如果你的retracing recasting
你只是非常近的话
它的效率非常的高
但是呢如果你射得非常远
比如说我一下子投个100米远的话
它的效率就会非常的低
那我们就有一个比较漂亮的想法了
我们呢在worst space里面预先放好一些prop对吧
这个prop里面呢我就把那些远的那些lighting
把它cash在那
这样当你的这个screen space prop
我要取一个方向的锐的时候
我就可以找一个沿途的比较靠近的一个worth
Facet pro
我把你那个方向的光线给你取出来
诶
这个想法是不是很有意思
哎这真的是很有意思
因为这样的好处是什么呢
因为如果你的场景啊不怎么动
你的你的哎这个已经跳到后面去讲了
但是其实这两个真的是有
就你会发现它确实没有办法顺序讲清楚
因为如果你的场景是一个相对静态的场景
光源呢也基本固定
比如说主要是太阳为主对吧
你的相机仍会走来走去
那你screen space的一个probe啊
其实一直是不稳定的
每一帧都要去更新
对不对
但是呢我家是在worst space里面
预先撒好了一些problem
这个worst space prop
假设我用clip map方法去部署的话
前面已经讲了无数遍了对吧
我动的时候我只需要在边缘处增加几个problem
后面删掉几个prop
这件事情我就搞定了
其实我只要更新一点点的prop
但是的话呢我就可以获得一个远处很好的
这个光线的这个采集
所以这个地方的话呢
lumen就非常聪明
他说哎我还要再做一层worst space radio cash
而且呢它的目标非常明确
就是你去解决比较远的这些光怎么来好
那么这个里面这是我们土法炼钢啊
给大家那个截下来的这个图
你看这个场景都是我们自己搭的
嘿嘿除法连高
然后呢这就是workspace probe的这个分数
大家看到没有
哎他一样的也是个clip map
所以呢他给了一个很神奇的数字
就是六十四十八乘三对吧
我也不知道为什么是48×3
但人家就选了这个数字
然后呢他大概做了四层对吧
大概clip map的距离大概是50米左右
那么它呢因为是worbased problem
因为他可能会被srt space兄弟们采用super space
大家记得它的采样角度是多少
在整个球面上也就8×8
其实球面上8×8
自己想想是不是非常的稀疏啊对吧
那我作为老大哥
我放在外面是作为你们的参考的对吧
给你们试试你的最后的救赎者
那我是不是应该踩得更密一点
这样的话
无论你是上面那个球面的那个那个SCRESPACE
Prop
还是下面那个problem
你这个方向随便来
我这边的力度都扛得住
都跟得上对吧
你看从这张图上可以看得比较清楚
所以呢它这个采样呢就会这个比较密一点
它会踩到什么呢
32×32
差不多1000多个瑞
大家想想这个RESPACE这个worst space prom
它就是比较霸道一点
他第一个他踩的距离远
第二个呢它的采样密度是高的
这样的话我很多时候screen speed pop
它不用跑很远
它只要跑到附近的
what's the problem就去借他的光嘛
哎这里面就讲了一个很有意思的概念了
叫connected race
我把光怎么接起来
这里面就有点像老中医接骨头啊
就是这个光我们把它分成一节节的
也就是说the screen space那个problem里面呢
我只是踩这个瑞啊
就往前走那么一丢丢
当我走到这个临近的worst space
这个problem的时候
哎大哥你的这个方向也有也有也有人
你射出去了吧
那我就不走了
我就接下来问你了
说那边到底有没有东西
如果有东西
那东西有多亮对吧
这个就有道理了
所以呢这个时候呢其实它的方法就很简单
就是这里面有个很有意思的概念
就是说我在这个screen space里面去做retreating
的时候
我大概只会找最近的一个worst space
包围他的这样的一个bounding对吧
然后呢我取它的这个对角线长度的两倍
其他我就不走了
这里面有个细节啊
就是那大家会问这screspite prop
这个锐走的这个长度呢是不是个定场呢
哎其实不是
为什么呢
在近处的screen supp的话呢
他的那个workspace
那个problem的那个那个
那个那个那个那个就是那个那个WORKO啊
它其实密度会高一点
所以它那个距离就是比如说一米乘一米对吧
你两对角两倍
大概323米左右
但是呢如果你到了远处
一个它虽然也是在你的spring space
但是远处的一个房子那个地方距离你看50米
在那个时候
你的这个就是war space的那个那个
那个那个WALKO啊
他其实已经比较大了
所以那时候的RIN呢跑的距离就会比较远
诶这个地方一定要注意这条
千万不要写死了
他这个是有很有很深的道理的
那同样的就是我的word space probe那个那个瑞啊
它采样的时候它也会skip掉自己的对角线
长的那个距离
就是我没有必要进出的
我不要踩了
因为我认为进出respace pop已经采完了对吧
我只给你提供你踩不到的地方的一个rap
这样的话我的recasting的这个起点可以往外推
这样变相呢也可以缩短我的距离
同时避免重复采样
你看这个事情是不是很有道理好
那这个时候呢当然了
会有很多的artifact
这里面讲一个很有意思的artifact
就是说哎我毕竟啊
就是我从这个screen space设一跟ray出去啊
你很难找到exactly
就是我即冲过worst space
那个那个那个那个点的
那个中心点的
这个这个
这个那个就是那个那个那个那个workspace prom
同时呢我又那个瑞呢
我只能沿着那同样的方式去找
那这样就会产生一个很有意思的问题了
这个artifact这个ARTIFA就很有意思了
就是原作者提供的嘛
就是说哎我在screen space找了一个probe对吧
然后呢他在worst space那个
因为我是跑出去去找的嘛
那world space的话呢
他很可能会跳过靠近我的一个阻挡物
我这个时候就会出现漏光的问题对吧
那怎么办呢
哎这个rendering的万能的hack大法就来了
我们就让光线弯曲一下嘛
你看就是说我们做这个gaming啊
就rendering有一个很神奇的东西
就是我们有的时候呢其实是不是那么特别care的
物理的完全的正确光线需要它拐弯的时候
它光线就给我改拐弯嘛
他的想法其实蛮简单的
就是说你求到我的那个最近的war space
那个那个采样的SFL那个编码
我可以找到你的焦点
我用那个焦点和你的中心去找一根线
然后呢我用那根线的连线出去
其实光是转弯了
但是这个转弯的特点就是说避免了不正确的
这个就是说visibility的问题
但这个呢实际上啊我个人认为是一个hack了
但没关系
但是但确实它能解决一部分的漏光的问题
但不是所有的问题
其实这个案例给的不是特别好
其实我本来想改一个这个图
这个案例会看得更清楚一点好
那其实呢我们的worst space这样的一个problem呢
放在这了对吧
那大家仔细想想
就是每一帧我到底要更新多少
我SPM呢
哎这里面就有一个很有意思的细节了
这个这个这个很很重要的一个实现的点
就是说其实刚才我讲了这么多的probe
但是在lumen至少我自己看下来他的shading
我们看下来shading是什么呢
它还是用screen space prom
因为你只有这个screen space这些这些pixel是有用的
因为我去渲染它对吧
worthy prop只是帮助我去快速的去采集这些
帮我这些在就贴近我物体表面的这些prop去
或许远处的光线
所以呢那我的word probe去采样的时候呢
如果这个这么大的空间是没有东西
而且也没有物体
也不在我的spring space里面的话
其实那些地方的problem是不需要采样的
诶这这就很有意思了
所以呢他这个WORKO啊就是worfacet prop
它只有被screen space prop有差值需求
有什么叫有差值需求呢
就是说我的那么多screen prom里面
它周围的八个spice pop它会标记为marked
那只有这些被Mark的worst space park
才有必要进行采样
所以它可以采集的那么高
什么30 243 12对吧
也可以踩得很远
就是因为他不需要
那个刚才讲的是48×48乘48
再乘4×4
那么多的problem
每一次都要去更新
那个就是那么多的瑞
他其实不需要了
第一个就是它只有Mark的worth space prop
需要被更新
第二件事情呢
唉刚才也讲到了
就是你不动的时候
如果场景没有变
光没有变
它也不需要更新
你看它这个地方是处理得还是很巧妙的
那么这两个光接到一起的时候
你看到它就启动
比如像这张图里面
如果你只是用这个screen space的这个这个prop的话
他如果只有2米的话
你看到的结果大概是这个样子的
但是呢如果你word space给它增加一下
你可以看到这个光看上去就准确的多了对吧
你看到这个结果就看起来更加符合我们retracing
真正一个想
我们这个就是GI真正想实现的效果对吧
OK好
因为大家看到就是在没有这个
这个这个就是worst space prop的时候
它实际上这个光其实是很不正确的
是漏了很多东西
因为很多WZ它不对
但这个时候它的光就相当于正确一点
就是原作者给出来了
那我们就假设他说的都是对的
好哎呀
我们已经三个小时了
很棒啊
看来我们今天要刷新记录了
lumen确实确实是个硬菜
真的是个大硬菜
OK好
我加油加油
继续大家讲完啊
我已经开始讲的有点耳鸣了
OK好
那接下来最后一步呢
其实也是我们最后呃第四个face了
我忘了写face for了
你看这个这个这个确实这个写的太仓促了
那么其实就是说我要去shading了
我要去把这个屏幕上每一个像素都要给它点亮
那我就用用什么呢
这里面有一个细节
就是说我要用screen space pro
所以刚才折腾了那么多东西对吧
他最后呢他还是在每个screen space的prom里面
把这个光啊给收集好
真的这个真的很折腾
大家看看前面我用match card生生生成了那个car surface
对吧
我还做了works lighting
大家还记得那个work lighting的东西吗
已经忘了
差不多对不对
好
这个时候我在进行screen space
这个这个probe reciprom呢
我还要对它进行这个adaptive sampling对吧
然后呢我发现这光采样的距离不够
我还得在这worst way再给它加一个pro
把它光给它接上
然后我还得要进行filtering
还进行important sample
搞来搞去
搞到最后诶
我最后还是在屏幕空间生成了无数的
密密麻麻的screen space pro
好
这个时候我们呢怎么办
哎呀伟大的super homex就起作用了
因为虽然我做了important sample
但是呢是实际上如果对intro lighting
我假设真的用它一个方向采集的光啊
他那个光啊还是很不稳定
还是有很多的JER
那怎么办
我们就把这些光全部投影到S上面去
其实S本质上是什么呢
相当于对我们的整个这个intro lighting光啊
进行了一个低通滤波
把它变成了一个低频信号
那你啥也不干
你把这个光投影到SH之后
哎这个property它就引用它来做shading的时候
它这个样子看上去就柔和了非常多
那么那这就是我们最终那个设定的这样的结果
看上去就很漂亮了对吧
当然大家知道如果听懂我前面讲的东西
就知道这张图是不正确的
为什么呢
这张图上面那个prop的采样是uniform的
对不对
我们刚才讲adaptive
下面还有很多小的那个就是8×8的
4×4的东西挂在下面
但没关系
这不重要
这是细节
最后你能看到这么漂亮的一个结果
那么总体来讲呢
lumen是一个非常复杂的系统
其实今天我讲了讲这么多啊
讲了快三个小时
lumen本身讲了快两个小时
实际上它还是有很多细节我没有展开
因为他真的是个非常工程实战的一个方法
也就是我为什么在前面花了那么多时间去讲
那个去lumen的那个那其他的GI算法
因为它真的是这些GI思想的集大成者
包括我还怎么备课
紧张了
我还把dd g r给秒掉了
本来我还给忘掉了
我还想讲一点那个哈very retracing的东西
后来想想算了
来不及了
我们就全部扔到二零系列的课程吧
我们就一零系列先讲到这儿
那简单回到lumen本身的话
就是这个OVERWORLD
我们去讲一下
就是说实际上呢他是利用了一个核心思想
就是对于不同的retracing啊
其实在硬件上它的成本是不一样的
其实最快最快的就是基于global s t f对吧
那其次呢就是在屏幕空间
我进行linear的step去插值
那么比他稍微慢一点的就是match sdf
就PROMASHSDF差距那个retracing
但是呢这里面有个前提条件
就是说你这个跨的步骤不要太大
不要一下子involve太多的mesh进了
如果你太多的mesh的话
它速度其实是非常慢的
那么high zb呢它其实这个respace retreating呢
它稍微比这个linear的step要慢一点
但是呢它的这个cos要高一点
但是呢它的准确度其实会更高
他比那个neon step更高
那么hardware retreating的准确度肯定是最高的
但是呢他的cost就比较大了对吧
那么就是hardware的这个基于的surface cash
我也可以进行hardware tracing对吧
当然我讲过就surface cast
它本质上是IMPOSTER对吧
但是呢它的成本也很高
这张图也是原作者给出来
就是他你可以看到他在工
因为他要解决一个非常难的一个工程问题
就是说在一个实战的游戏里面
真的把这套GI算法变成一个real time
而且能处理很多的动态光源
这种复杂的情况
以及包括刚才我讲的
我个人觉得非常巧妙的就是那个surface cash的方法
因为我以前特别难以解决的一些
比如说自发光的物体怎么去照亮环境这件事情
他好像就自然而然就把这问题给解决掉了
好
那么其实呢
这里面这就引入了一个大名鼎鼎的一个图
就是说诶lumen到底是个什么算法
有人就说包括我自己以前也黑黑他
我说lumen他就是几个算法的缝合怪对吧
那为什么大家会说这句话呢
实际上就受这张图的影响
只是官方给出来的说诶我在每一个SQUEEPROM
我到底是怎么获得他的这个IRRADIANCE的
就是他的radiance的那红色区域就是什么呢
我是用screen space的垂线的方法获得了非常快
那么绿色的区域是什么呢
我是用mesh的方法取得的对吧
blue呢就是哎我我mesh df
如果蓝色的话呢
它就是在这个就是说更远的
我只能用GLOBSDF去的
其实这个地方讲起来就很糙了
但实际上大家仔细看
如果每一个pixel
他的那个就是那个他做那个prop train的方法
是单一的话
我们应该看到什么样的一张图
是不是应该三个颜色的图
但现在我们看到的图是什么呢
是个渐变图对吧
所以我大胆猜测一下
就是说对于每一个RECIPROP
我要踩这个八乘八六十四个方向
那么这64个方向里面有多少个方向
我是用screen space trace多少
我用math df的trees多少方向
我用这个global df trace
其实呢在这里面是有一个权重的
所以我们可以看到这样一个渐变的东西对吧
那更具体的详细的去讲啊
就是说其实lumen的核心
我觉得有个核心的点是怎么快速的做tracing
那么它这里面就讲的就是说
第一他首先的话是用scratch screen space trace
我如果呢它基于high zb去trace
最多50步
如果能trace得到
那很好
我就把这个结果拿过来对吧
如果screen space trace我拿不到怎么办
我用mesh sd f trace
那match stef trace的话呢
我其实你可以发现它trace的距离非常近
只有1.8米对吧
他这原我们是在这个代码中翻去看的
然后呢
就是而且呢它只在
就是说这个位置在我相机的40米之内
我才会用mesh staff
那这个时候呢我可以返回更详细的数据
就mesh id啊
这个hit word position啊
normal啊对吧
我可以直接把他送到我的final
我去sample in他的final好
因为我有那个surface cash
对不对
那如果再远一点
比如说200
这个就更远的距离的话
我一次性这假设前两个条件都不满足
要么你推线的距离太远了
我特么1.8米配的东西
或者说我的这个position就是我70的position
超过了40米怎么办
我就一股脑设20米的阴影
瑞我走我我用的是什么呢
我只用global s t f
但是呢GLOBTF我能拿过来东西什么呢
只有walker lighting
所以works lighting其实非常的重要
对于我们的整个lumen的这个广场的采集
因为你可以理解成就是problem
是我采集的结果
但是我采集的源头
下面是我的surface cs和我的works来
下次我有更多的学习准备的时候
我可以把这个图画的更清楚一点啊
否则的话这些概念是特别特别容易混淆的
然后呢这里面再补充一条
就是原原作我没有讲的
就是说如果我的global sdf这个tracing对吧
re retracing也失败了
怎么办
诶其实人家还有一招
你就踩到天球上去
铅球我们就sky sky box上面
你天球反正是无数无数无穷远
对不对
我采来的就是天光哎
这个hack其实非常有道理的
因为大家想想看
就是说对真实的场景表达的时候
我对上市的很多problem
天上有蓝天白云啊
这些东西鱼可能云还在动啊
那其实它对于我表面的光照
其实影响还是蛮大的
天光其实很多时候是很亮很亮的
所以我觉得这个其实不是hack
如果我们在写lumen的时候把这一趴少写的话
我个人觉得对效果应该会影响特别大吧
OK所以这就是一个整个lumen他的这个tracing呢
它整个结果
所以这样的话大家就能理解那张图
它到底在讲什么好
那其实这里面呢我要特别想high一下SCI对吧
SJS这个怎么说呢
听上去是一个hack screen space对吧
但是呢其实lumen他SDI在lumen中还是蛮重要的
这也是那个官方给的一张图
就是说如果我只有龙门
我看到的结果是这样
大家可以看到下面那个倒影看着很粗糙对吧
但是对于高频的
对于近出的这些东西的话
其实s gr还是蛮重要
大家仔细比较一下这两个字的区别对吧
所以所以说呢我要小哦
假设有人想黑鲁班书啊
你下面用的就是SC
这个黑的就是既对也错对吧错
肯定lumen本身很复杂很丰富
但是呢
lumen确实离了SCI的一些基础思想的话
确实也很难work
所以我一直认为就是lumen这个方法很了不起
他是过去这十几年吧
我们对real time gi的研究之后
一个集大成者
也是第一个真正把GI哦
应该不能叫第一个
其实以前有一个我记得有个中间的叫什么lighten
他也尝试把dynamic gi变成软碳的
但是呢这个这个这个公司
好像现在据说是不在了
没关系
大家会前赴后继
那么我们去做这样的一个real time gi
的这样的一个方法
OK那么其实lumen呢他最了不起的地方
我觉得还是在工程上
他真的完成了交付
也就是在PS5的这个硬件平台上
大家知道PS5它的GPU还是很强的
但CPU其实一般吧
GPU其实也跟现在的这个显卡来讲
还是有一些差距
但是它能做到3.74ms就做完了对吧
而且呢如果你愿意把这个屏幕的
比如screen space那个light problem
Worst beat problem
分辨率在下降那个四倍对吧
但你其实你的效率可以更高
就是可以从将近四秒3.74ms啊
下降到2.15ms
刚才讲错了
不是秒
是毫秒
秒就完蛋了
哈哈秒的就是offline的那个计算了
那么当然了
这里面你去SACRIFED
你去损失掉的是什么呢
哎就是精度
那这里面你可以看到
就是这个里面的话是相对比较low
resolution的
这样的一个就是screeneprom or swift prom
你看到这样的一句
这个结果去看上去已经非常非常amazing了
真的
但是呢如果你用他的FORESOLUTION的时候
你可以看到更多的这种光照的细节
所以其实1616的这个pixel的这个选择
我相信这个作者自己肯定也做了大量的尝试
也就是8×8肯定试过了
32×32肯定也试过了
这可能是他们最后觉得是一个
大家最能接受的东西
而且这个东西我猜呢可能和他们在UU5里面
和这个就是NI的这种复杂的场景
这个密度去进行了一个配合
他们选择了一个最好的这样的一个适配哇
我们已经讲到了哇
我的天呐
讲到了11点了
同志们真的要陪我翻页了吗
好OK那这是他lumen的一些结果了
这边说实话
这个结果我个人觉得还是非常的了不起
就是它基本上就是过去一些offline的这个
这个这个retracing的这个render的结果
其实就是我们很多比如说室内设计师
效果图公司啊
所梦寐以求的一些效果啊
金一天的话随着硬件的发展
随着算法的发展
我们几乎可以实时的产生这个结果
这个其实对整个电影行业
对于过去那些离线渲染行业的冲击的话
还是包括动画电影行业吧
我学的都是一个巨大的影响
也非常有非常巨大的影响对吧
这也是奠定了未来10年
我们下一代的游戏引擎的渲染了一个基础标杆
也就是我们认为GI应该是下一代
顶级引擎的标配
就是你只要做下一代引擎的
你的基必须是摇弹的
而且这个呢我认为lumen呢
其实只是这一系列伟大征程的开始
真的这是我个人的感受
就是说你可以看到lumen还是做了大量的妥协
也是基于这一代的硬件
在未来10年随着硬件的发展的话
real time gi的话将会变得更加的成熟
可能会变得更加的简洁
所以我认为lumen是这个方面的开山鼻祖
就奠定了这件事情
所以我觉得他的创作者的话必然会载入史册
而这是我个人作为一个程序员吧
我觉得还是要这个奉上我的这个这个双膝
就是表达这种敬佩
这工作做的非常的了不起
OK好
那最后啊今天时间非常的仓促
所以我根本就没有时间去写总结
那最后呢想到了用一张图去表达我的心情
那又把我们的祖师爷卡基亚给举出来了
就这张图
大家记得我们在那个rendering的第一节课
用了这张图
所以说其实啊我们整个rendering体系
我们在解决的就是这个问题
就是怎么样的把卡提亚的这个方程real ta算出来
其实这里面lumen只解决了GI吗
比如像TRANSLUENCY啊
像那个fur啊
像透明物啊这些东西的渲染对吧
其实还是很复杂的
所以这其实也是未来我们的
就是游戏引擎的一个征程对吧
所以说对于高级的游戏引擎技术
其实
所以大家如果真的想立志进入游戏引擎行业
我觉得大家一定要做好就是啃硬骨头的准备
千万不要认为游戏引擎是一个哎人人都可以
哎呀
我这句话说的是不是打自己的脸
我说人手一个自研引擎
那今天我要讲另外一句话
就是游戏引擎其实深度非常的深
他真的是计算机科学的最前沿的东西
就是有很多很复杂的技术
所以的话呢就是我们要有敬畏之心
对这种前沿的技术好
那接下来呢就是我们这节课的reference
课程组的小伙伴们还是花了很多时间
但在这节课我们真的是特别特别的干
真是爆肝啊
就就好多次开会开到晚上11:12点
就大家一个算法
一个算法的撤开一个一个就是因为很怕讲错
虽然我一上来先挂了个免死金牌
如果讲错了
大家千万不要打我
但是呢我们在准备的时候还是态度端正的
就尽量避免讲错
所以我们还是花了很多时间
去研究这些相关的东西
这里面有些东西我今天没来得及
比如像DDGI对吧
其实大家有机会可以真的去研究一下这些东西
包括像SDFDDGI对这些东西
然后呢解压的话有一系列的东西
包括像hardware tracing
有些东西大家都可以看一看
大家也可以想想
就是有HARBTRACING之后
那lumen这样的框架怎么去优化
其实他们原作者也做了一些
有团队还是花了很多时间去做了很多工作
我们我真的再次感谢我们的课程组的努力
然后呢我其实是一个工具人对吧
我负责把这些知识表达出来
剩下的东西啊都是我们课程组小伙伴
他们真的在过去的
可以说是一个多月里面非常的辛苦
因为lumen的这套体系非常的复杂
然后在课程的最后阶段呢
我们又提高了要求
就希望能够把GI的整个体系给讲清楚
所以大家又去展开了做了很多的研究工作
那我们也争取奉上了
这个我们能拿出来最好的一个讲GI
讲lumen的这样的一个课程
希望同学们能够接受和喜欢好
那接下来同学们有什么问题问我们对
第一同学问我的第一个问题
就是说硬件光追发展的这么快
但是lumen还是做了一整套基于SDF的这个软件
光追对吧
那就是说在未来的这个引擎里面
软件光追和硬件光追是不是都是必须的啊
这个问题实话实说啊
也是我最近思考的很多的一个问题
因为harry tracing呢其实从NVIDIA在猛推这个东西嘛
实际上我们都看到他的potential
比如说我们现在是三零系列显卡
马上我们将面对四零系列显卡
据说四零系列显卡
他的那个real time retracing的能力又会加强很多
但是呢就是我们真的实测下来呢
就觉得hodor retracing
它本身的这个能力还是没有达到
就是我们的需求
因为其实我我上次我现在讲三零系列显卡
我们测了一下
大概是啊十个billion
就是100亿的retreat recasting profit啊
per per second1秒
那这个呢作为这个GI来讲的话
其实还是不够
尤其是你说一次半次两次半次对吧
但是呢其实就是lumen自己的作者
他们现在也在尝试
就是说如果你有harder这个retracing的话
我可不可以用harder retracing取代掉部分的
比如说基于距离场的这样的一个retracing
那这个方向呢我个人觉得还是非常值得尝试的
但这件事情的话呢
我个人觉得蛮挑战
因为lumen本身是一个很复杂的系统
他最后能work啊
其实他每个参数都是很精细的
调校过的
包括lumen
如果大家真的去玩它
你会发现他还是有很多broken case
就是我们最近我本来那个来不及了
否则我给大家展示一下
我们最近自己用虚幻五搭了很多case
我们就看在这种场景下
不但是这个绝对不是黑龙吗
恰恰相反
我们很清楚你做这样的一个real time
接下算法的话
其实你很多时候很难做到
就是说面面俱到
那反过来讲
就是说现在我自己认为比较大的一个不确定性
就是说hardware retracing这件事情到底能走多久
因为大家知道现在的显卡
它本身已经做得非常大了
功耗已经很高了对吧
我们已经基本上hit到了摩尔定律的一个
一个一个边界了
在未来的比如说5年或者10年
hardware tracing可能它的性能会增加一个数量级
那他可能对于GI这个问题的话呢
并没有本质的去改变
那么另外一个就是在很多场景下
比如在游戏主机
它的硬件换代速度会比较慢
比如在移动端对吧
它的硬件换会更慢
那这个时候我们怎么去做一个积压的方案
所以我个人觉得就是啊
lumen的局距离场的这种reaction的话
很可能还是目前我们找到一个比较好的一个
software retring的一个方案
对
这是我目前我对这个问题
我保持的是一个open minded
就是还是开放的一个状态啊
对这个同学问的问题就是直击灵魂
他说lumen的效果非常的好
但是呢听完我们的课
就发现这个系统非常的复杂
那是不是那个就是我们要就是是不是很难维护
对吧
那我们要不要开发这样一个类似的系统
那这个问题其实是一个直击灵魂的一个问题啊
就是啊lumen是一个非常非常复杂的一个系统
所以我觉得呢大家确实可以认真思考一下
对于你自己的case对吧
你是不是实现它的部分的算法
实现它部分的效果
比如说我在B站上
看到很多小伙伴会发一个视频
说哎我自己实现了lumen的效果对吧
然后做的很漂亮
但确实是就是说
如果你不要达到那么高的工程级的需求的话呢
你可以取他部分的算法
也能产生非常好的效果
但是你把它全套的算法全部实现一遍的话
这个对你的编程功底
数学功底
包括系统功底要求确实是挺高的
而且呢刚才同学问的那个问题
提到那个点
就是说他是不是好维护
我个人觉得也是lumen
接下来面临的一个非常大的一个挑战
就是说因为我们在做游戏的时候
就知道游戏引擎它所面临的场景是极度复杂的
举个例子
比如说刚才我随便提了一个东西
比如对于地形terrain
你没有办法生成mash card对吧
你没有办法生成Mac mashcard
你就不能够直接把它放到那个那个surface cash
里面去
那这个时候他怎么去进行这个采样
那么第二个问题呢
比如说像中间我刚才讲的有些气体
participate media对吧
就比如中间有一团雾出来了
对不对
那他的鲁门怎么
它的光照怎么去处理
那还有呢对于就比如说非常动得非常快的场景
这里面很多东西都在动对吧
那这个时候因为他动的速度非常快嘛
比如说我要做一个像sonic这样的游戏对吧
大家跑的非常的快
那lumen能不能work
所以这些东西呢
我个人觉得都会是一个实战化的
lumen系统的一个很大的挑战
我们也非常期待能看到几U5的
有lumen全态效果
这样游戏出来
这里面的话
也能对这些问题给我们提供一些参考
我的预测就是说啊今年明年吧
GDC上应该有一系列的实战的游戏
产品的文章会讲到
就是说在自己的产品中
我用lumen这个技术
我需要做哪些调整和优化
才能实现一个真正的sheep wall的
这样的积压的效果
就是sheep就是什么呢
可以发售了的一个解压效果
因为今天lumen的demo to be honest
他还是个技术代码
它还没有变成一个商业级的产品啊
第三个问题就是很有意思
他问我说
实时动态GI
会不会成为下一代这个3A游戏的标配
那我个人的观点是yes
是的
因为人眼就是这样的
你一旦被training好了
一旦习惯了那个东西的时候
你是非常不习惯那个东西是没有的
那么就是GI这个东西呢
它on hand off其实直接就定义了
你是一个就是就是像古老的这种塑料化的
这种渲染的感觉
和一个你感觉很实景化的感觉
就像刚才我展示的那个几个
就是那个室内仿真的那个效果嘛
那个效果的话呢如果再去调一下
它已经非常逼近于你用相机拍出来的效果
那么一旦人接受的说哦
游戏就应该是这样的话
那大家其实可能很难接受这个东西没有的情况
包括我也看到有些人很有意思
就是用GI的效果
再加上那个就是NP2就是什么呢
就是卡通化的渲染
它也能产生一个以前的那个卡通化渲染
不能产生的效果
所以我个人认为就是说啊虽然它非常的难
非常的复杂
但是的话呢可能未来五到10年游戏的主流
可能就是这个方向
因为硬件的算力啊也会逐渐的增加
所以这里面的话呢也会给我们提供更大的空间
所以啊其实说实话
我并不认为
lumen今天算彻底完全解决了积压的问题
但是呢它确实是在整个游戏GI的这个历史上
迈出了我觉得是关键性的里程碑性的一步
好的那今天的话哇
将近三个多小时我没有刷新的新的记录
怎么样
同学们对我们这一节课的内容还满意不满意
那我希望我们的肝对吧
中秋节都没有休息
我今天是我压力最大的省份
今天下午都快已经爆掉了
你知道吗
我准备课的时候其实非常暴躁的
因为每个细节我都会扣
那anyway
就是说啊希望同学们还满意我们的这个结果
然后呢最后再跟大家预告一下
我们啊明天会有我们的50万播放的彩蛋出来
也跟大家嗯轻松一下
换个换个脑子
另外一个的话呢
下节课两周之后
我们给大家讲NNIGHT
那又是一场硬仗了
真的是一场硬仗啊
希望同学们哎呀
我得吃点补品吧
然后那个然后呢
我们104的课程就第一趴就算全部结束了
希望同学们也会喜欢我们这个课程
然后后面的话呢
我们有更多的精力可以跟在皮克罗上
包括在更多的一些内容专题上
给大家提供我们的帮助
也很希望就是呃怎么说呢
能够把我们中国所有热爱引擎开发的同学
聚集起来
我们一起做一些有意思的事情
好谢谢大家好
我们下两周后见拜拜